Camille is in Oahu Hawaii hi Camille
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello my
dears are you doing better than I
deserve how can I help
yeah so I'm 22 years old got married
four months ago with no kids yet
I just immigrated here to this state so
my husband is the only one working while
I'm slowly waiting for my work for me my
husband and I are done baby steps one
two and three already and we're already
working on our baby steps for good for
you now thank you
my concern is recently I have the
opportunity to learn with learn hands-on
with Tim Sykes for stock trading now the
registration fee is quite half-filled
six thousand five hundred and that's
separate from the money that we would be
investing now I don't have six thousand
five hundred lying around my question is
should I borrow that money from our
emergency fund and if we do we still
have three months of emergency fund left
and whatever your 500 well I'm not
familiar with the exact course that
you're talking about but obviously I'm
familiar with the concept of buying and
selling stocks or day trading if you
want to call it that all of your
research shows that 78 to 84 percent of
day traders lose money and 100 percent
of them think that's not them and that
includes people who take courses like
you're talking about I can find that no
data points that show on a consistent
level across a broad population the
people that take a course like that
become wealthy as a result because
buying and selling single stocks is
ultra high risk and truthfully Wall
Street Journal or example had a big
piece of research as they print on the
front page a few years back that they
took a
a blindfold and put it on the guy put
all the stalks on the wall and threw
darts at the wall and they bought those
stocks hypothetically and then they used
some of the top players on Wall Street
to pick a portfolio of stocks and the
blindfolded guy beat most of the top
guys and it was a trick it's not the
research is not real there was a trick
here was the problem they were only
allowed to pick five stocks and then the
problem is that that with that little
amount of diversification which single
stocks always caused you to have as a
small amount of diversification you can
get no safety and so the volatility
caught even the guys who were smart the
volatility catches them and so you got
to have a broader base than that and
that's why I don't buy any single stocks
personally and now I found some I know I
have some friends that took their
companies public and made a couple
hundred million that's different I know
some people that buy and sell some
stocks as a small percentage of their
world it's almost like a hobby for them
and some of them make some money but
it's kind of like a fishing story it's
always talking about the one that got
away or they're always talking about the
fish is always bigger than it really was
when you actually go back and look up
the returns so I just don't do it all of
that to say so all that say I wouldn't
do it number two would I take a course
of any kind and pay for it with my
emergency fund no because it's not an
emergency okay use your emergency fund
for emergencies